[Music]
surprising news
uh ladies and gentlemen about harry
potter star daniel radcliffe have you
heard this
shocking revelation daniel radcliffe
admitted he's had sex with harry potter
groupies
that's true yeah his exact quote was i
put my wand in their chamber of secrets
[Applause]
[Music]
this is absolutely true radcliffe said
that he has had sex with harry potter
groupies yeah radcliffe said he's
looking forward to someday doing it with
a woman whose retainer doesn't get stuck
in his wizard hat
you have to take it off
get back
thank you
i was shocked by that aren't you shocked
by that i'm more shocked how does the
retainer get on the hat no
man what a square
didn't you experiment in college
not with hat sucking oh man
my best sex has been in a wizard hat i
got to tell you
and there you are uh
she's here tonight uh
or him whatever ladies and gentlemen
the 80s was a crazy time
let's change topics uh three wins
yesterday for rick santorum
yeah
the uh
you don't have to vote right now
i was doing the setup to the joke and
people were letting me know how they
felt no three wins for ricks and trump
since uh since yesterday's primaries
rick santorum's campaign has received
250
000 in donations
yeah when mitt romney heard this he said
250 000
oh
that's cute
aren't you a good little kid
speaking of romney this is crazy a
condom company has launched a special
line of mitt romney condoms
yeah the romney condom is perfect for
the lover who likes to constantly change
his positions
[Music]
i just wanted to get quoted in the new
republic i didn't
that's all i wanted
hey this is crazy a retired general uh
is saying that the navy seal commander
who ran the osama bin laden raid should
stop talking about it
yeah
when asked for comment the navy seal
said sir with all due respect i'm trying
to get laid here okay
back off
back off that was more
true than funny uh
check this out
no transition just check this out
check this out
crazy news out of china a mother in
china gave birth to a 15 pound baby
yeah chinese officials say it's so big
it can do the work of two babies
[Applause]
hey
check this out
like a magician distracting you from the
joke that wasn't good
over here
nothing over there
no
over here
this is crazy story hackers were able to
hack into the president of syria's email
because his password was one two three
four five
yeah when he found out the president of
syria immediately changed his password
to six seven eight nine ten so he's in
good shape now he's fine
new product new product that lets you
that's coming out soon that lets you
consume caffeine by inhaling it
yeah the product brings starbucks one
step closer to its ultimate dream
charging nine dollars for air
they've been thinking
you